with six million young people in Europe
lacking either a job or training
placement many analysts are warning of a
lost generation a new franco-german
initiative launched in Paris on Tuesday
aims to prevent that sutoko silly day
dunno up the whole European ideas at
stake it nobody thinks the European
Union can take care of all our needs but
the EU should at least give its citizens
hope and protection this builds into
politics to the measures include helping
small and medium-sized businesses get
loans to expand operations and create
new jobs for young people another idea
is for more countries to adopt Germany's
dual education system with on the job
training and young people are to be
encouraged to move where the jobs are
could you mention young people in Europe
are waiting for answers they need to
develop their skills and get job
experience and they can do that wherever
there are job openings albeit spits
isn't specifically that could mean more
young people from Spain Greece or even
France moving to Germany where currently
more than 30,000 training positions
remain unfilled